welcome to another doctor Center chalk
and talk this one a little bit different
than some of the other ones where I've
been answered questions that came up be
you or YouTube or emails this is
actually coming from one of my online
classes teaching ethics we are in the
first week and one of the things that i
that i did was i solicited questions
from students i always want to know
where the students actually are
sometimes it's hard to get a handle on
that especially the older that you get
the mortises that you are from students
in your occupation and age and that so i
always ask them something a lot of the
lines of what are some issues that you
find confusing questionable concerning
bothersome etc etc with methods and this
time i got a particularly rich rod so i
don't just have one question of dealer
I'm dealing with common concerns about
ethics they come up at the very
beginning of trying to study it in a
coherent systematic academic way and
it's interesting because part of what
these were flat i'm going to read
actually some of the excerpts from
things students your writing is the fact
that we live in a society which is
almost in many ways as a society
schizophrenic about about ethics and by
that i mean that it has very incoherent
notions about it and there were all
throwing their non jumbled up together
and there are there use this is in fact
something that many different
philosophers can
as a key feature of late modern culture
and of liberal democracies in general so
not a big surprise but every generation
finds a troubling and every generation
of students winds up having to grapple
with these these problems because you
can't get away from right wrong good and
bad just and unjust even you know noble
of Bass Pro girls we want to put it
these are perennial human concerns and
the fam you happen to be in a society
where these things are not dealt with in
variable here in manners to the most
part there is a lot of moral talk and a
lot of ethics talking society a lot of
use of moral concepts language a lot of
procedures a lot of rules but oftentimes
is not very well explained or very well
thought out and that confuses people
that it raises problems for the problems
that are not just you know mental
confusions where they they feel like
they want to think this out a little bit
further but even on an emotional level
and you can sense it and some of the
things that they're saying so before I
actually do it I want to read try to
talk about things with a portable read
some of my students anyway so one of
them said since there's so many
different perceptions of what kind
wrong it becomes challenging to judge
when an action is actually this guided
for instance serial killers and some
criminals don't actually see anything
wrong with the crimes they commit yet
the majority societies it all by their
behavior also it's unacceptable to kill
someone yet some people believe in
criminal takes it online so there's a
death penalty thus we are in turn
killing them when I was younger it
seemed like the difference between
behaving in this behavior was concrete
yet now it seems like every action can
be manipulated and beautiful things so
my question is how to draw the line
between great wrong actions and is it
even possible to do so now what then
that last part isn't even possible to do
so that's not a abstract academic you
know idle question that is a genuine and
systema the lot of people have and I'm
finding more and more students in my
classes over the last 10 years who have
come to me and they actually are deeply
concerned about this and you know this
goes back to one of the other doctor
Sayle the chocolate talks where I said
yeah we should actually be teaching
ethics and teaching it in a fairly
systematic way that gives students
something that they can actually sink
their teeth into and wrap your heads
around take home with them not just you
know character development or be nice to
each other
if you do this there's these consequence
the real actual little theory we ought
to be putting that in the classroom
because it was happy with getting
students who are coming to us and
they're getting an ethics balance and
they're already worried about is this
all bs is this personal opinion does
this all just flop that I cathode you
know like learn a little bit of so I can
talk the language when I need to because
that's a lot of other people seem to be
telling them so there's a real breather
here's another one similar line the
better question that there might
actually be what truly is good and bad
in the world human nature offers so much
diversity that it seems hard to even
fathom in uniforms were wrong code so
again the challenges can we actually
provide some sort of coherent ethical
theory some sort of coherent practice
another one says I believe that good and
matter based on individual perspective
rather than circumstance depending on
how are you raised your taught about the
values of right or wrong good to be a
determines valuable act your actions may
not conform to another interpretation
these same ideas some people believe
that what they're doing is right even
when the majority of society thinks that
is wrong there is no real way to draw
definitive line marking the difference
between the two terms notice that's a
dogmatic assertion there is no way to
draw a definitive line marking the
difference between the two terms it's
reflective of a lot of people's
attitudes with a coming to an ethics
class here's a different type of
question my question is what happens
when you need to do something for the
right reasons that might be an unethical
or vice versa where is the line where
something is bad enough to be considered
unethical but still needs to be done and
when thinking in the other direction
where is the line we're doing something
ethical is still a bad thing sometimes
situations come up and it's difficult
so I want to do because the ethics
involved the very moral language often
ends up being confusing and I think that
we all get to why let me continue with
this great question I know what you mean
sometimes there are situations which are
bound to present with an unethical
element this concept leads to be a part
of the idea that perhaps were faced with
the issue how much unethical behavior
and what level of unethical behavior
were willing to tolerate here's another
telling another person what is right and
wrong is no doubt an imposition of one
person's belief government perpetually
does this a lot of regulations of course
isn't following people should never
broke a placement of government as
government is not a thing rather a force
German vandals would care actually
that's showing some interest in
sophistication in understanding how
government works ethical questions are
present throughout all of this as
people's ethical beliefs that drive
people walking at an interesting desire
to impose their ethical beliefs on other
and others is that not the government
essentially is a big collaborative force
of imposition here's another one my
question concerning ethics is who is the
one to determine what is truly right
what individual may think that what
they're doing is completely fine while
the individual next to then making it
goes against everything they believe
since it's based on personal beliefs I
don't understand have any authority but
a label and what people can or can't do
finally I've seen there's been a lot of
discussion but what's right or wrong
quest
topic a lot when comes to workplace
situations I've always struggled to wrap
my head around some of the situations
because walking seems like all solutions
to the issue could be right in some sort
of way my question right versus wrong
when you're in the office sugar does
authority of expectations and desires
always make things right when you're the
working work there's a lot of ray area
for me I can't stay at fully understand
sometimes I doubt anyone being able to
give me the correct answer so what are
we happy if we put these together as a
sort of count as a picture we have a
picture of a few different stances you
might say for one thing ethics morals
are seen as being ultimately something
that's contested something about which
there is no general agreement but also
something about which people generally
everybody has some sort of view and
interestingly there is this worry
because these are views about what's
right and wrong or what's good and bad
that may be all of the views are wrong
or all of them user right views let me
say that one more time there's a worry
that maybe views in ethics because
they're about writing wrong and our
individual
collectors that those themselves are
just all right or all wrong there's a
kind of not necessarily despair but a
sense of resources where do we turn to
this seems like you know everybody else
has got some sort of answer but these
answers don't appear to be all that
satisfied because of the situation in to
find instances this is a real problem
this is a genuine situation that a lot
of people not just students at various
college but all over the world are
finding themselves in and so I wanted to
say a few things about this i'm actually
using this not just as a doctor scared
of chaka khan for my class as a set of
responses so i would put first of all
you'll identify some of the key worries
and concerns and I'm talking about each
one in turn because a lot of times if
you look at all these with you know
without differentiate him they seem kind
of overwhelming they each lead to each
other actually because these are
actually all connected with each other
but I have a council actually treating
them one at a time in isolation and not
expecting too much not expecting
somebody to provide you with an answer
that will be immediately convincing and
sell everything rather this is the sort
of thing where we have to model through
it and puzzle it out and bits of it
start to become more clear as we go on
that's why you can't just you know learn
ethics by just getting a textbook you
have to
think your way through it work your way
through it do some practice through some
reflections anyway let's go to it to the
Excel figuring out what really is right
or wrong or good or bad this is the key
concern keeps coming up different people
have different views okay that's great
is it any different today than it was in
flavors done if we read platonic
dialogues we actually see that a lot of
people do in different views not only
does it vary from culture to culture you
know play those times are the Greek's
variant or even engineer different
Greeks the Athenians versus the Spartans
it also buried you know classes swad
things differently upper class saw
things differently the burning class saw
things differently about the lower
classes swapping the slaves individuals
see things differently that each other
yeah most importantly people can change
the minds people can leave one
perspective and go to another because
they think that other perspective is
actually better perspective different
people have different views yes indeed
different people do have different views
about ethical issues is that by itself
problem it's only a problem if you
assume that someone all the fact that
they have different views is actually
relevant to whether their views are
true or false or whether we can arrive
at a better view not necessarily need
one single view that is absolutely
correct across the board but certainly a
better view than some other people do
you want to say that the serial killer
is on the same level with a contract
killer for that matter certain is even
worse on the same level as the ordinary
citizen when it comes to the morality
killing don't think you do but being
able to articulate why that's that's the
case that's the challenge and if you
don't have that available to you right
right away the answer reason wet study
ethics that's a reason why to think
about these things why does seek out the
answers you have two different people do
have different views but that doesn't
mean that everything is up for grabs
there are people out there who will tell
you that well because everybody's got
different views we can all do as we
choose or none of manners or anything
like that most people are generally
there to try to either manipulate you or
they feel bad about themselves and the
things that they do that's why they say
that's the mere fact that different
people have different views does not
constitute an obstacle to ethics or mean
that you can't count arrive at correct
moral judgments as a matter of fact any
good moral theory includes within itself
as one component an explanation for why
is that different people have different
views so if you replay if you read a
result you read John Stuart Mill if you
read count you will find out they will
say yeah other people do have different
views here's why here's why there are
other views are
not as good as this view over here so
that by itself is not a knob see but I
understand why it does seen a case can
be made for each of you that's an
interesting thing to point out that's a
real word a real concern what is one
that actually is sometimes made worse by
what we do at ethics classes including
my own at this class because one of the
things that I'm getting have my students
do every semester is take situations and
then explain to me how would you look at
it if your analysis how would you look
at it if your day an apologist how would
you look at it as a negative us and
there's this this you know they're there
are a lot of things that from this
perspective they seem wrong in this
perspective they seem okay from this
perspective they seemed like the thing
to do and that can lend itself very
easily to this view though there's just
a bunch of different theories out there
and everybody can find some theory to
latch on to in any given case and make a
case for themselves and why what they're
doing is right that can they do a kind
of pessimism as well the thing to keep
in mind is not all perspectives are
equal the mere fact that somebody can
make an argument for their position
doesn't mean their argument is good
doesn't mean that that it's right for
them to make that argument that the
premises are actually true that their
line of reasoning doesn't have flaws of
it but you have to actually look at
those things and again this isn't one of
those things need to result that you
have to develop some experience that is
it also that's a real legitimate concern
there's going to be inconsistency
sometimes too this is a real live issue
one reason that people give or saying
the capital punishment is wrong it's
just another form of killing and killing
another figured if you're killing a
person because
killed some of the officer just
replicating the bad action now if that
was you know so easy and open and shut
there wouldn't be anybody engage in
capital punishment because back you know
thousand years ago people have said oh
that's a pretty simple argument that
convinces me I guess that settles the
issue so there's got to be more to it
than that right the figuring out what
that more to it is that requires making
distinctions and that requires some
practice and that requires using some
moral theories that requires you know
some some thinking on the reflection
some some apparatus and discussing
things with other people and there's a
lot of saving inconsistencies here's the
takeaway I would like you to have here
when you run into an inconsistency
there's so many different things you can
do what is it a inconsistent therefore
can't be true that's not a smart thing
to do because there's a lot of things
that seem inconsistent at first glance
but then when you look at them more
carefully and you make the right
distinctions and bring into right
concepts turns out there actually isn't
that that inconsistency there it
actually does make sense so you don't
want to have a knee-jerk inconsistency
I've done reaction another possibility
to do kind of despair when it's always
in perfect nothing's that were good we
can't do ethics well that's not a 10 it
could be that everything isn't perfect
but you can still distinguish between is
this more perfect is this less perfect
as this got less intense
see this over here does this make more
sense than this and if that's the case
take this that makes that's what makes
sense the other thing is you can do is
you can actually investigate it look at
it and figure out what everybody is
inconsistent higher order differences in
operating codes authorities situations
one of the real worries that is out
there this is expressed by these
students is you know not only do we have
different views of that was right wrong
why don't we have a little different
view as well because different people
have taught us those views so if we go
to those who teach what's right and
wrong we don't find them in agreement
either so it's not just a matter of us
Porsche laps down here who you know
haven't been like studying the stuff
saying hey I don't agree with you and I
don't agree with you when we turn to
authority figures if we all turn to the
same authority figure hey were okay but
there's a whole bunch of them out there
and they don't agree with each other
either so it's a higher level that's
real problem I can understand I can
relate to them I know what it feels like
to not know who to turn to to and I also
wanted to like to have to turn into the
wrong person and get there you know code
there this is what you need to do then
it turns out to be the wrong thing and
you trusted the wrong person but I
notice can you ask yourself is there a
right person is there a wrong person are
there some people you just shouldn't
trust with are there some moral codes
that you look at yeah i know people they
follow them but that can't possibly be
the right way to go yeah the mere fact
that something will do follow but that's
this just this problem here i have
different people have different views
not all views are eating not all views
are on the same level so the same thing
is going to come
you want to critically assess the
different views see what there is in
favor of them see if they can justify
their position see if they can explain
themselves in relation to other
positions here's why my position is
right and those people over there say
something different but here's why their
position is wrong if a position can
actually do that and be fair to that
other position and provide good reasons
for that you probably should take that
position that's probably making an
advance sometimes we have competing
values and we're stuck in ethical
dilemmas yeah that's true that's not a
reason for us not to be able to do with
this that's a reason why we should do
that that's a reason why we should
actually explore the whole theories and
figure the bottom valve and think our
way through them because if there are
genuine dilemmas out there there's a
hole they do exist I think when they
exist that's a sign that something is
going wrong and you kind of retrace your
steps and figure out how do we actually
get here in the first place and that as
well what are we able to do it is this
present situation sometimes you actually
can't maximize the good you can only
like you minimize the amount of the
harbor people this that doesn't mean
that's not doing a good thing or that
you know that would be the right thing
to do so all these are genuine worries
genuine concerns but they don't get
their not reasons not to study ethics
to make progress in general despair or
be cynical there are actually reasons
why you want to thoroughly throw
yourself into study guides the last
thing i want to say instead of making a
couple of important students and again
this goes to some aspects of our culture
particularly in academia and also other
other areas where i think that things
have gotten kind of modeled for our
younger generations our generations are
not a very good job presenting coherent
clear messages making moral judgments
you want to do this and you want to do
it well because you cannot be a ethical
person you cannot be a moral person
without making judgments saying this is
good this is bad this is better this is
worse it's not a question of whether you
make judgments it's a question about
whether you make them coherently whether
you make them correctly whether you make
them reasonably whether you make them
well whether you check them against
other people's judgments whether you try
to resolve discrepancies whether you're
fair with them that's the real question
not whether you should think more
illusions about and anybody who tells
you that you should not make moral
judgments watch out for that person
don't trust them because there's
something wrong either it's a weakness
on the part that they can't take other
people making moral judgments or they're
trying to manipulate you in any way
they're not doing any good for you so
you have to be able to make more
deliveries is that the same thing as
being judgmental no they get overlap I
mean you can be judgmental by making
moral judgments being judgmental means
on the one hand perhaps making moral
judgments but making them on bad grounds
you know I like this person so they're a
good person that's not a reasonable way
to make moral judgments you can like all
sorts of people turn out
at people and you can dislike all sorts
of people who turn out to be good people
if you dislike people a venir you know
you find reasons you know moral judgment
based reasons to dislike okay probably
being judgmental the other thing would
come in how you may actually express the
judge how you form the judge you go up
to the person that you think is doing
the wrong thing and say hey look I think
you're doing about thing or do you like
you know talk about them behind their
back and say watch out and they're doing
the wrong thing you're an awful person I
think that's being judgmental we could
talk horrible I want to give imposing
morality and others this is a real
worried that my students gave is it okay
for us to impose our morality and others
there's some that you better impose your
morality on or somebody else had better
do it otherwise those people are going
to be a danger to us and to those that
we care about Syria example an extreme
case there's plenty of others as well
and they are right to point out that
when we have governments or we have
organizations or you know social
connections or cultures those of our
collective ways of imposing some sort of
morality and others it's not whether we
impose more reality there's again it's
whether it's actually done in the right
way imposing could be an awful lot of
things ranging from reasonably trying to
convince a person to you know and poked
into putting all sorts of force and
coercion to bear those are not exactly
the same
thing right one is difference what is
coercive the other one is reasonable but
you know we do have to impose some
degree of morality and others and others
have done it with us yeah the question
is whether we're doing it right whether
we actually have things right that we're
imposing other people whether we do it
the fairway whether we do it in a
thoughtful way whether we do it even
sometimes in a loving way but I want to
say one other thing making moral
judgments is not the same thing as
imposing one's morality on others if I
say to you when you're doing his role on
I am not imposing my morality unless you
want to stretch the meaning and imposing
so far that it covers just about
anything if I actually said you're doing
the wrong thing keep on doing the wrong
thing and Kelly now i'm clearly imposing
right or if i say in an ethics class i'm
a virtue of the system if you're not a
virtue of this is your funk in my class
that i would be able to but merely
making moral judgments is not the same
things in postcards moralia so you know
those of you who are worried about that
we're afraid of people calling in
judgmental afraid of accusing you of
imposing your morality and others when
they do that just tell them hey I'm
making moral judgments I'm entitled to
do so I'm a human being this is what
human beings do this is part of what
makes us what we have two other things
that are different than just making
moral judgments that I want to also
distinguish from up and say these are
good things what is providing reasons
our justification for it's one thing to
say this is wrong it's another thing to
say and here's why it's wrong that's
important you want to be able to give
some sort of reasons and maybe you have
to work these reasons out as you go the
reasons will get better
go on for why you think things are wrong
or right good or bad also you should be
reflecting on the moral judgments that
you make and when they need to be
revised you should be revising them
that's like a that's also what it means
to be a committed Lee ethical person it
doesn't mean that you have to say I'm
not going to make any any judgments
until I've got everything completely
right no you're going to make some
mistakes the question I've said this
many many times in my ethics classes a
lot of ethics is not doing the right
thing the first time it's actually
figuring out how to fix things after the
screwed it up the first time and
figuring out what the right thing to do
is in that situation and our reflection
really profits from those sorts of
things and we only have to revise things
if we got them wrong in the first place
that's part of the process so if I had
to sum all this up in one phrase i would
say have courage have the courage to
actually taste he has to say i think
some things are right something's are
wrong here's why I think so I'm open to
revising it but I'm gonna say it after